Welcome everyone
to the first meeting of the Fundamentals
of Active Inference textbook group in
2026.
In this first meeting
we have already said hello and sort of
grounded and
created a preliminary connection
and we're going to go over the Coda
document that's our shared epistemic
niche for a few minutes.
Address any other general or logistical
questions about how we'll work over the
coming couple of months
of course with updating and surprises
along the way.
And then we will discuss the
introduction chapter
as much as we can linearly synchronously
and also with an emphasis on how do we
write a question in the Coda and that's
really going to be like the way that we
continue to augment and incrementally
share our curiosities and insights is
really through the questions that we ask
and the ways that we kind of chime in to
contribute to each other's questions.
So looking at the Coda document on the
side
it it may be dark mode or maybe in light
mode for you. I'm using the dark mode.
The top-level page is going to have a
kind of link tree with all the
information that you might want and if
you want something added up to that top
level, feel free to go for it. But
everything that we're going to do is
going to be in this chat room
synchronously and in this document
asynchronously. So bookmark this
document and continue to revisit and
enjoy it because it's going to have a
ton of awesome material in it.
First tab is the meetings tab.
This provides information on exactly
which topic will be under discussion for
that synchronous meeting
the date and the time in UTC.
Also everyone's been added to the
calendar like the overall Google
calendar and the specific events. So if
you ever have uncertainty about what
time zone something is happening in,
different time zone shifts happen in
different locations or not
check your calendar as reference point
and what is going to be discussed in
that session.
It's not required to have read the
material before, let alone feel like you
have reduced every uncertainty about it.
PS that will not happen.
Um so feel free to jump in whenever you
want to enjoy it live whatever your
level of
uh readiness or preparation for it is if
you've submitted questions ahead or not
and also who will be the facilitator
during that session and then after I
will add a link to the recording.
Silvia?
Yeah, um is Fraser's the Friday's
session at 1:00 or at 2:00 UTC because
it seemed to be different from the
invitation's time.
It should be 1:00 UTC from what I
understand but
Britain is currently on British
summertime which is 1 hour ahead. So
maybe maybe somewhere in there.
Okay.
>> Okay. Okay, no it is
I'm going to thank you. It is at Is it
at 1:00 because right now RXNFER is at
1:00 on Friday Fraser.
The 13:00 UTC.
It is yeah so I would
currently it is it is at 1:00. We've set
it's at 1:00. So and that does conflict
with the RXNFER session.
>> Should I delete RXNFER session?
I think I think that's probably wise.
All right.
All right. Thank you Silvia great note.
I will have just deleted the
RXNFER Friday session and move the
calendar event to appropriately 13:00.
So good call. Yes as as um hopefully all
will will see and and co-enact together
like
changing your mind, changing the world,
belief updating is the name of the game.
That is the true learning by doing
because it's such a lifelong journey to
have an analytical grasp of some of
these topics even in our AI augmented
day and age. So like hopefully that is a
a spirit that carries us through and
keeps it fun and and dynamic as we fix
typos
ask questions and like keep on evolving
along the way. So check back at the
recordings
column after the meeting if you ever
want to revisit anything.
Um next tab is the participants tab.
This is one of my favorite figures I
guess you could say. This is from the
form that people register with. So the
x-axis is self-assessed familiarity with
active inference.
Again whatever that means on a 0 to 100
scale for different people and then a
given person who might say okay yeah you
know 40.
There's a point in the green, blue and
red for their self-assessed familiarity
with computer science, biology and math.
So I wouldn't exactly say it's a uniform
distribution hypercube. There's
definitely fewer people above 80
self-assessed than below but like as our
introductions reflected and as this
quasi quantitatively shows
we really come from a variety of
backgrounds and sort of starting priors,
orientation and preferences.
So
it's a good thing to keep in mind along
the way. There's something that could be
super obvious day-to-day
10 years ago for you that is just the
next amazing new thing for someone else
and that's part of the fun of having
such a collaborative group.
Also this table you should be able to
and if there's ever like an issue with
what you can or can't edit in Coda and
you want to be able to edit more then
you should be able to request that
access.
Um but this table you can add your own
information if you want to
have it out there and connect with
people. Okay, directory is just like a
table of contents if you want to look at
some different sections.
Onboarding, that's what this meeting is
about. So and also another useful tip in
Coda, you can click on someone's icon
and you'll jump to whatever page they're
on. So if it's ever like flipping by and
you're you're not seeing what's
happening on the sidebar
you should be able to like just click on
somebody's name and you'll jump over to
where where they are in the document.
Um so
Fraser has prepared some information
about this reading group itself.
There there's so many ways that that we
can say this and and the book kind of
stretches the limits of linearized
presentation of this material which is
massively non-linear
and extremely custom to different
people's backgrounds and familiarities
and directions.
So what we're doing here is this many
coats of paint
co-learning
where we're seeking to learn locally
understand down to the sentence level,
down to the figure level or the
formalism level and also at the same
time building this bigger coherence for
our understanding.
Different facilitators, Fraser, Andrew
and myself
have different styles and and
preferences and a huge amount is very
emergent based upon who's there and what
has been submitted ahead of time. So
can't can't be pre-stated per se.
Usually though it'll begin with just
welcoming, starting the recording
jumping into like what are we going to
be looking at? Okay, it's chapter five.
It's going to be like this in the big
picture not a lecture or anything like
that.
Um and then if there are pre-submitted
or pre-addressed questions that are
epistemic in in the eyes of the
facilitator at that moment, that's where
we'll kind of begin
and or
the questions that people write in the
chat which we'll work to kind of
integrate into the Coda so that it makes
a more durable record.
So that's laid out
in this section here.
And um
we will continue to version this as with
all pages
in terms of participant expectations.
Everyone's going to be preparing. Some
people are going to be pursuing this
like a graduate seminar level of
possibly multiple hours of self-study
and and peripheral familiarization per
hour of synchronous meeting as one might
expect from that kind of a seminar.
Other people this may be the entire time
of their attention per week on the
topic. Other people may never join a
meeting and just view the recordings or
look through the document. So there's a
large uh kinds of ways to participate in
the group and we we welcome those all in
a broader spirit of respect in science.
There's never test, grade
judgments
on on what we do and and don't
understand.
Everyone unl- is it just it's it's a
fair blanket statement that everyone
will have things that they do not know
and externalizing that, making that into
a known unknown
distributing it getting that to be
resolved in the questions table is going
to be a key piece of just like
well identifying what we don't know
reducing our uncertainty closing the
loop, moving forward and in a couple
months it's going to be possibly quite
transformational what our own
understandings are of this area amidst
other developments in research, other
live streams happening at the institute,
other ways to just like step up and step
in as things continue to change.
So,
Andrew and Fraser and I are committed to
hopefully keeping the show on the rails
and starting and ending relatively on
time,
respecting the work and and Sante's
contribution
without um
pedantic
lecturing
without any other number of fallacies
that a facilitator could step into and
hopefully trying to keep everything
curated in this document.
Uh participation guidelines just like
broadly, we're in a creative commons
space, in an open science space. So, we
acknowledge and abide that we're not
going to share any disrespectful or
proprietary information
and that what is in these recordings and
what is in this document are part of
like an open public shared record
and all that accommodates that and we're
here to learn, yes, apply
along the way and after
and also learn here. So, keep that hat
on.
Learning practices a lot of times it's
like, okay, learning and applying active
inference
but how?
And again, that's going to look like so
many different things for different
people and we can add to this table.
However, these are some ideas about
like, what does it look like when you
want to time box and kind of check in to
studying, to learning
contributing to your internship,
advancing whatever it is that you're
looking to to do.
It can look like reading in a variety of
ways and there's other practices that
you can engage in.
And also there's other activities
happening at the institute, other
projects that you can take a look
through.
There's also a lot of ways that you can
contribute to the textbook group
right now
like in this meeting and in future weeks
and also over time
different ways, cohort after cohort.
Like we did nine cohorts of the 2022
textbook
and Andrew facilitated many sessions and
other people made different demos and
built a math learning group for some of
the more pre-fundamentals type stuff.
So, it's like if you're looking for a
lane to contribute
those are out there and if you want to
make a new lane, then that is also an
option.
Okay, that's that top level
fundamentals. So, this is kind of a
course logistics, onboarding, meetings,
participant information and so on.
Now we get into this second section,
which is the fundamentals book itself.
Now, the book is currently not open
source, though in the future it may be.
So, what we are not able to do is screen
share and scroll through the book itself
or
put up like extensive sections of the
book directly. So, we'll be referencing
like the one and only version and the
page numbers and so on.
Um and we are able to pull out the
equations and the figures, which will be
able to embed and things like that in
Coda.
So, in each chapter section, for
example, the intro that we're going to
discuss today
there's going to be like the figures,
which will scaffold a lot of our
discussion for all the chapters and
equations if relevant, but they're not
in the intro.
And then this is the questions
table.
And yes, I will make sure that everybody
who requested access to the Coda just in
in a
um
Yeah, I'm going to add everyone just in
a in a pause in the activities.
But just to show what the questions look
like when you have edit access.
The questions would just be like, you
know, what what motivated
Dr. Namjoshi
to write this book?
There is no question too simple or too
complex.
We do try to ground at least like one of
our pivot points in the book.
Like in this sentence it said this
how is that related to this? Like we can
have a quite broad stance.
It really does help though to connect it
to a specific figure, equation or quote,
grounds it in a little bit of a verbatim
situation, a shared reference point.
And then um people can upvote those
questions. We could add some other
emojis if if people want to um
emote differently.
And then we'll when we're
working through the material, somebody
might write something in the chat,
somebody might write something or say
something just verbally
or you'll be able to submit these at any
time. You know, when you wake up at 3:00
a.m. and you're like, I know that
there's something happening on page 244
or whatever it is.
And then like
we'll pop it up and it'll be like, okay.
So, yeah, what what did motivate Dr.
Namjoshi? It was like, well, he was da
da da da da da da da da.
And then that becomes a more durable
reference points.
And then also it becomes possible to
reference everything in Coda, everything
is an object, every page, row, etc. is
is an object in Coda. So, we can see
things like, oh yeah, what what did
motivate him or um
okay, figure 0.1.
Oh, okay. All right.
So, in in that way with a little bit of
Coda hygiene we'll be um
able to
start with what may be initially an
epistemic gray zone or fractal nested
uncertainties
and really get some awesome clear
questions. Like, why is it called free
energy? What is a principle? What is
active inference? These are all great
questions broader and narrower than
that, too.
And you'll have at kind of mouse over
glance
the ability to pop those questions open
and we can we can build multiple
perspectives and put a ton of links and
things like that into uh
those sections.
So, like for reference, here's the 2022
Coda
and in in the questions
we see just broad notes associated with
like, well, how how do priors get
established when there's a novel
encounter in the environment? Those
kinds of things people can write and
maybe they're legitimately an open
research question, maybe it's open and
shut.
So, that's the chapters section.
Then we'll have the figures table. So,
as we go along, we'll curate the figures
in
for
each chapter.
We'll have the equations table.
We haven't added in the end because
we're going to this first pass through
the book
we will be, you know, kind of putting
the planks ahead of us as we go.
But again, for the 2022
book we have LaTeX for every equation,
screenshots
translations using the active inference
ontology
philosophical implications, like there's
a lot of composability and combinatorics
that we can do with these kinds of
tools.
So, we'll get there along the way and
that again it it enables stable
reference and it prevents us from sort
of engaging with a with a shadow of
variational free energy
rather than an actual claim, especially
because I think as the G form of
variational free energy and all that
kind of stuff, which is actually
introducing some detail and clarity that
is otherwise absent essentially from the
ecosystem. So, it's going to be new to
everyone and making clear stable
references is going to be really
important for all backgrounds.
Boxes and tables, we'll see if we can
screenshot those out. Um
then that's the book itself. Such as the
chapters, questions about the chapters,
figures and equations, boxes and tables.
Then we have sort of discourse, which is
like that's where in the peanut gallery
in these groups. Um it's an active close
peanut gallery, but one nonetheless.
And so we curate all of our questions.
This table is going to be
massive. Like if each person
makes that contribution to write one
question per week
some of you are going to
pop off 50 questions per hour. But even
if everybody were to write one question
per week, we would have hundreds of
questions over the coming months. Many
of them addressed as well.
In the code section
we for some people on their learning
path is going to involve a lot of code
applications and developing kind of
everything from interactive dashboards
to more robust
packages.
And we have a fundamentals GitHub repo
that we can add people to if they want
to contribute that way. And also here's
a a table
with with several dozen active inference
implementations. So, if people are
looking for open source
examples of active inference?
You'll find
dozens of variety of kinds.
Um applying active inference we is is
always a a hot and fun topic. People can
share their projects.
There's an ideas and insights page
for just like if it's not a question
it's like oh like this clicked when I
saw that or this figure helped me
understand that.
Those don't even need to be framed as a
question if they don't feel that way to
you.
Resources, this has been added to and
curated over the years. Just variety of
background materials.
This book has a lot and still
people are going to find going upstream
and downstream is going to help a lot.
Future textbook groups.
Ideas and suggestions for what we could
do in future groups.
A lot of ways that that was explored in
the 2022.
Math learning group, it's pretty minimal
here, but um
that is probably going to be a fun
little subgroup and we've had just like
separate meetings for math learning
group depending on if people want to to
do that.
Uh errata
is if there's a typo
in the book.
We worked with Sanjeev for like 18
months
um
over the last two three years
to
find many typos and and suggestions
in the sort of beta testing of the book.
And
there are still some typos or
ambiguities in this version. So if you
find something
like
write it down.
And then we'll present these to Sanjeev
uh for inclusion in a future version.
And
Sanjeev's obviously not he's not in the
room with us right now. However, he has
indicated that for
sticky questions
and at some points periodically he will
be available. So hopefully we'll we'll
do right by preparing and curating and
have some opportunities to ask him
questions, get questions explored
meet up with him and so on. And then
last is just a few tables that might be
relevant. So like the ontology which is
actually the distilled
core generic linguistic and technical
basis of active inference.
Research table.
I've I've just completed with Joel Deeds
and other literature scale
meta-analysis, but these are just some
papers if you want to search for things
and live streams the the several hundred
live streams on a variety of topics. So
if you're just curious about like what
about social
or what about physics?
You'll find all kinds of different
things just by learning and going
through this table.
So in the sort of breadth and depth
T-shaped exploration that we're all on
it can be nice to like
scroll through and just see yeah what
are the titles? What broadly has
happened at the ecosystem and institute
over the last five six years?
And then when you see something that's
exciting or or curious to you just
pursue that until you tap out.
So those are all the pages.
While I go to another window and add
everyone who requested Coda access in
does anyone want to ask a question or
anyone who has participated in past
textbook groups want to share their own
tips or or anything?
Um this may not fit with your protocols,
but I I find um
I find Coda your explanation really is
very engaging, but I find it clunky and
uh
Microsoft like or something. Um as a Mac
user I find it quite uh
uh
it just doesn't engage my my mind.
And um I'm
I've been in various other things where
WhatsApp groups have been set up by the
participants, you know, so that there
might be a question you don't want to
put it up in perpetuity within this
Coda, but you know, you can create a
kind of live dialogue about the thing
that you're having
difficulty with understanding as you're
reading the book. I don't know whether
there would be a subset of people here
who would be open to
uh developing a WhatsApp group that
would just be a live interface to
support each other on this journey.
So put in the chat the Discord link and
there is a channel in there.
I don't think we'll start
uh WhatsApp today, but it's thank you
for the suggestion. We'll keep it in
mind, but there is a channel in the
Discord for that. And yes, totally makes
sense.
For some people Coda is like a jungle
gym.
For other people they they
don't interact with it. So it's all good
and we'll make sure everybody is is
still in the game.
Any other like comments or learnings
from people's past textbook group
experiences?
Or Maybe just really quickly
uh Daniel maybe a few people don't seem
to have added access when it comes to
Coda. So I'm I'm not really sure they
the best thing to do would be to reach
out to Daniel
uh I suspect or or um
I'm not quite sure how how people don't
have added access can get it. So Yeah,
request access if you see the button
or just email
admin@activeinference.institute
or put your email in the in the chat and
and I I just added it to several people
who requested.
So just I I I see those requests and
I'll just I'll just approve them one by
one instead of just adding many people
in at once who
haven't necessarily even joined.
Yeah, but I'm I'm I'm seeing all these
requests. So you're all you'll be added.
Yeah.
I'll chime in quickly just uh
yeah from facilitating previous textbook
groups uh yeah Daniel has definitely
already highlighted this, but
everybody's coming from you know, very
diverse backgrounds.
Uh I'm personally looking forward to
this new textbook and going through it
uh and and kind of capturing everything
that's going on. It's so much more
comprehensive than the previous
textbook. And that said we're going to
be facing uh head-on much more in terms
of like breaking down the mathematics,
looking at a lot of mathematical
notation um and we'll also be looking at
the relationships between that and
different theories of the brain but sort
of as a a backing. So we'll part of the
um suggested reading for this week was
the appendix A at the end of the
textbook and I definitely depending on
if we have time to get to it today or
not uh I definitely recommend reading it
for those who are more interested not
just the mathematical but also sort of
the relationship with with neuroscience
and and and the Bayesian brain
hypothesis and all the rest.
Yes, Sidon and then anyone else?
Um yeah, so
um I had gone through the first book
a few introductory chapters of the first
book and coming from a math background I
had this question that it the the
central idea of active inference this
idea that
you observe
uh
uh states uh
so you observe things that your brain
predicts and then upon those
observations your brain changes
uh those post the prior beliefs. This
idea seems intuitive from uh
a lot of these visual optical illusions
that you see when your brain kind of
predicts that there's something there,
but it's not actually there.
Uh but from prior experience your brain
is predicting that. So that seems
intuitive. But my question is that all
of the further math that I saw in the
book uh
the KL divergences and
uh calculating the entropies uh what is
has there has there been any empirical
grounding or biological
you know, experiment or links to
neuroscience with this mathematical
framework yet? Or is that still an open
uh science question?
Oh, it's it's such a deep question. You
you will find many resources on the
empirical statistical like modeling
biological data sets
on to the more first principles
axiomatic
and you'll even encounter on the
meta-science or philosophy of science to
what extent are we looking to first
principles axiomatic derivations or
biological data set fitting or not to
justify what?
So it really raises the question of what
is needed to how do those cross domain
and cross modality conversations even
happen? Does fitting a data set really
well in a given situation support or
reject a given framework? Like if a
height and weight linear regression
works super well, does that say
something about linear regressions? What
does that say about the world?
How do we deal with map territory
issues? Are we looking for empirical
biological grounding or what kinds of
intrinsic and extrinsic coherence
does the framework have?
And what can be
what can what can be said within and
across those different domains of
evidence?
And and and thank you, Andrew. That's a
great um um
paper to to
um bring in like specifically exploring
like
what is the empirical
status
of predictive coding.
But it's to just sort of footnote it,
there may or may not be something about
neurons in a given data set for a given
scientist in a given experiment at a
given moment
that does or doesn't invalidate
variational principles of least action.
So actually understanding how those
roads together come together
and rhetorically how people position it
is everything.
Okay. And then like that like
these are how we distill out those
questions. I mean bubbles up over
studying it.
And then we just
can add more background to the question.
And then people can say, "But but what
about this and this?
But what about
And then we'll have philosophy, first
principles, mathematics,
statistics.
And then those puzzle pieces all on the
table
start getting curated together and then
there's a bigger picture that each of
those domains wouldn't be able to make
alone.
Right. That makes sense.
Um
Okay.
Yes, and the stream
of that.
So again, if you request edit access,
you'll be able to to jump in. So just
whenever we're discussing a question,
we will just have have it up here
so that we can all just in case we we we
blipped in or out for a second so we can
just see clearly like what what are we
what are we addressing here? And kind of
pursue it to a little bit of a
um
some sort of resolution.
And again, some of these are going to be
open and shut
one sentence response or see here.
Others are going to be open research
questions, especially when they get into
the real adequacy and validity of of
applications.
Many of those are
unknown or undone or proprietary.
So there's going to be that edge that we
come up to.
And and and many people will build build
and and fly over that edge. So this is a
good way to
to see where that is.
Um
the introduction chapter, if if somebody
in the in our last sort of 10 minutes to
to give more flavor of how most of the
meetings will will
go.
Um if there's like a page or a quote or
a section that anybody wants to go to,
raise your hand and go for it.
Or
we can look at
some of these
>> [snorts]
>> three figures that are in the first
intro chapter.
Um if I can just jump in actually, I I
had a question
unrelated to to introduction.
Yeah.
Um
I had the 2022 textbook and I've been
playing around um
with getting the the textbook uh that
Sanjeev obviously um created. I was
wondering whether it would be possible
to follow along decently well or like
code on um effectively
with the 2022 textbook or whether
there's really new adapted and
um sort of like freshly created material
in this new one. I'm happy to buy it.
It's just that
it's a bit tight. Um so so yeah, wanted
to see what the feasibility would be.
Totally understandable. It's an entirely
separate textbook.
Okay.
>> There's there's some conceptual
isomorphisms, but it's it's entirely
separate and different.
Um hopefully the the
group even for those who may not
purchase the textbook, there still will
be good learnings. Like it's not going
to be a um
"Oh,
we're looking at secret page 75 and
discussing which word is the 11th one on
the page." It's going to be like
whatever we pull out will will make
legible here
with figures, equations, and quotes
and accessory material.
Mhm.
So it it it it should be understandable
even if somebody was watching the
recordings
or just looking through the coda.
If there is a um a discount that we can
offer, we will let people know.
But we don't we don't currently have
like a discount offer.
Yeah, I know, of course. I I don't think
it's going to be a problem. If it if
there's really low overlap, I'll just
get the new book. I I just wanted to
make sure that I wasn't like duplicating
things. Um but yeah, okay. Thank you.
Yeah.
Um okay. Um Pressure, go for it.
Yeah, I just wanted to say I guess uh
one thing that I want to do in my my
sessions, well one thing we all want to
do is uh all of all of all three of us
is make sure that we're able to like
present the material and talk about it
in a way that is going to cater to
people who don't have the book
physically.
Um cuz obviously you know, it is a big
investment and everything. So that's
hopefully that's one of the one of the
things that I'm going to uh try and do
is is you know, for those of you who
don't have the book, uh
at least these sessions should be uh
they should be useful enough to you to
be able to say, "Okay, here's the
high-level idea and and set of concepts
we're dealing with in this chapter right
now." Uh even if you don't have it. So
that's Yeah, just just on that. I mean,
it is this this book is like in a
different universe
uh when with respect to the the
pre-existing 2022 book from Parr et al.
It's a great book, but um this this new
one is vastly more detailed. So yeah,
it's definitely in a in a different
league.
Yeah.
And we'll look at the concept maps that
kick off each chapter.
You'll notice that
if you search for the word forthcoming,
you'll find many references in the
beginning, in the middle, in the end of
the book to a second textbook that will
come out
from Sanjeev in in the coming one or two
years
that's more about first principles of
intelligence, Bayesian mechanics, and
there's a great number of papers and
live streams on those topics. So it's
not that they're unknowable until then.
It's definitely a statement though to
help us contextualize that the free
energy principle,
a formal framework and the modeling
assumptions that go with it, has these
two
courses arising from it.
Active inference in terms of the
applications that
different agent modeling frameworks,
which could be purely in silico, could
be embodied agents, all everything that
comes along with that discussion, and
then Bayesian mechanics as a sort of
more general approach to state spaces
and and dynamics.
Um second figure in in the introduction
chapter
is from a paper I worked on with Blue
and RJ couple of years ago
related to just the the growth in the in
the field.
And just a
uh couple of days ago with Joel Deeds,
we published a a literature review
architecture that essentially scrapes
abstracts, plots field growth,
uses LLM to extract out claims,
um
plots subfield growth over the years,
looks at evidential accumulation with a
simple model over the years.
So um whether with in the way that we
sort of chunked out the fields, which is
not represented in in this um
overall bar chart, is like
A tier is core engineering free energy
principle and active inference,
which is the formal theory analytically
and some of the philosophy and
metaphysics, which inform each other.
The second ring, which is where a lot of
activity at the institute centers
around, is on tool and translational
development
between a core theory, which is system
agnostic. It has a lot to do with
complexity science, which was mentioned
by someone earlier, and system science,
and the domains, which are C.
And that is the question of whether
there's um does the drone fly?
Does the EEG classify sleep states?
Those kinds of questions.
And those are happening across those
different domains, so you see an
intersection of the active inference
ontology with domain ontologies and
applications.
The second figure in the intro is
looking at that growth
as proxy and limited as that literature
search is.
And then we get the third
figure,
which shows the dependency structure
and the parts of the book.
So part one is the fundamentals of the
fundamentals
of the principles of the free energy
principle.
But don't get caught up on that.
Fundamentals of starting with a thought
experiment kind of brain in a vat style,
but that's going to introduce us to
Bayesian updating
and quickly is going to get into key
topics related to
state estimation and inference,
variational inference, and predictive
coding.
The core active inference is going to
generally layer in
action, which is where we move from just
the passive Bayesian observer into an
engaged agent. Though, even a passive
agent can have its attention and belief
under understood as a type of mental
action.
And then the third part is applications
and extensions.
So, if we
kind of in our last minutes pull back to
the meetings,
we're in the end-ish of April.
Fraser's and Andrew's is upcoming
sessions this week
will be somewhat similar to this in
terms of them giving some overview stuff
and and people just raising these kind
of general initial questions about
logistics of the group and kind of big
picture like where where to start on
this, what kinds of resources are out
there for that.
Then
next week
we're going to discuss chapter one and
appendix A, which is the history part.
We're going to make our way
one chapter per week.
So,
tread lightly
with without haste, without waste
because
it's going to hit hard.
And you could spend multiple weeks
even if you're going to do it many hours
a day on some of these chapters.
So, we're all going to be like curating
out the figures and equations and
questions on this first pass.
There are 14 plus chapters. So, this is
already going to take us into summer
basically.
We could do two weeks per chapter. We
could do a month per chapter. You could
have a course on just variational
inference. So, there's a lot of like
fractal zooming and zooming out.
Hence, in a sort of community spirit of
co-learning, we just sort of try to hold
on
and set a clear tempo and keep to it.
And just understand that we are going to
revisit it. This is a significantly more
comprehensive textbook than the 2022
book,
which even
three, four, nine times through,
it has not exhausted the opportunities
for conversations and questions
at a super narrow technical, how do they
get from this line to that line?
And especially at these broader open
topics type.
And uh maybe we'll kick off another
cohort
in in September or something.
Maybe if everybody has a great time and
and tells their friends and is
interested, we'll
be able to do more and differently as
well.
So,
later in this week
at the times
oops
here
um
and otherwise
weekly at this time or whichever ones
are convenient for you,
we'll be
out here with the book.
Any last questions?
Yeah, Andrew and then anyone else and
then we'll close.
Yeah, hey.
Um
so, I understand the textbook is about
has an app a focus on applications of
active inference to engineering.
And I I often find that it's
for learning it's useful to have kind of
if not an actual project you're trying
to apply it to, like at least ideas of
things you might want to do.
And
uh I wonder if there's any
support through the
like if the textbook group or the Coda
is designed in some way to afford little
like projects or
at least thinking
collaboratively Yeah.
>> about projects.
Um
that the textbook might apply to. I I
saw on the site there's there's the
measurement there's the measurements
that there's something else.
Um
for proposing projects, but
Yeah.
>> that already requires some knowledge.
Yep. Yep. Yeah, great great question.
So, first like in the projects tab here,
you could just it could just be an idea.
You can just sort of without doing a
measurement or a proposal or anything
like that, you could just say like, I'm
kind of wanting to make a dashboard for
this or I'm I'm curious about applying
it to that. And like just by writing out
there, you'll have moved the ball
forward greatly.
Few prompts don't hurt as well. So, this
is just sort of people raising their
hand could be just an idea they're
waiting for someone else to join that
party or it's something like, yeah,
we're actually kind of like already in
motion. We have a a code base that does
this. We're looking for somebody with
this. So, it could be projects.
And then if to kind of pull back to the
institute layer,
there are many active projects
and you can propose a project that would
be have like more visibility in the
newsletter, the kinds of things that
could be on our public calendar, or you
can join into any of these other ongoing
projects.
And I there there's so much more I could
say on that, but yeah, like the water's
fine. Jump in. Make a splash.
Write up what you're curious about or
wanting to do just to see if someone
else is out there to do it or share what
you've already put out open source.
And there's
more to do than done.
So, essentially anything is relevant on
someone's at least on someone's own
learning path. Even completely
replicating and reproducing something as
exactly done elsewhere
will bring you right up to the boundary
of just like for example, an early stage
graduate student who's then able to take
the next step over the rest of their
training.
So, if that is relevant to someone, then
yes. Lots of different projects to um
to initiate or to join in on.
Thank you.
Yeah, and and if if for people who want
to do the the code,
uh they can share their share open
source things on their own accounts or
we can explore like
incrementally building dashboards and
things like that for at at this
fundamentals repo.
Yeah, just quickly with respect to the
code, uh I anticipate that this will
become something that we do and that
will become more important as we go
along. It can't be something that we
assume right now just cuz you know,
what's about to hit hard in this group
and everything. But that is one thing
that I myself am very very interested in
is building out the code examples from
the book and actually, you know, having
things that we can sink our teeth into.
That's really where the clincher will be
with this book, but um
we we will have to sort of see how much
of that we we can do. So, yeah, we'll
see. Yeah.
Yeah, uh uh I'll just second that on the
on the code uh cuz it it would be
wonderful to really build out all the
code for this. So, I'm looking forward
to contributing to that. And if anyone's
interested, we could potentially start a
uh kind of like a sub channel on the
Discord or even just start an email
thread. But yeah, feel free to reach out
to us if you'd like to be more involved
in that side of things. Thanks. Yeah.
And you can also in code it first off
just again request if you
um want access to edit the Coda, you can
always email
the address, reply to these emails that
you're getting. And then
you can do cool stuff like um
um you know, tag Fraser,
annoy him with emails at all hours of
the day, all that kind of stuff.
So, yeah, like you you know, um we we
can just put a I'll I see people writing
a little bit in the code.
I'll just write people interested in
code.
So, request access if you don't have it
and we can just continue from there. And
yeah, everyone everyone checks in and
out through these next months
and um we'll we'll see where it all
amounts to. Morgan?
Uh yeah, I was just going to say that
like uh Ryan Smith's, you know, SP like
uh
tutorials with code were
so so excellent. I would just love to
see that um in this as well, yeah.
Yeah, in a way this book's
structure
um in spirit recapitulates the
step-by-step
single latent state, single observation,
moving into action, kind of follows the
progression in Smith's
>> [snorts]
>> step-by-step model stream one
progression to a full POMDP. So, I think
we'll we'll see that drawn out at at
much greater detail
and and with more of a modern machine
learning twist rather than uh MATLAB SPM
type.
So,
thank you everyone.
Hopefully this has actually raised more
uncertainties than closed, but but we
got we got we took care of some of the
simpler stuff. So, future meetings and
uh weeks
we're going to be
jumping into these chapters and it
should be awesome. So, thank you again
for for daring and for joining Open
Science and the institute and all that.
And see you next time.
Bye.